with characters like Injustice Superman
and the Batman who laughs recently
gaining popularity and then losing it a
month later by being in too many things
all at once I always wondered what it
would be like for more Marvel characters
to go bad in an alternate universe we
got ultimate Reed Richards putting on a
Bionicle helmet and being a creepy
weirdo but not really an equivalent
Justice Lords or crime syndicate
that's why I think it's really cool that
the second spider-verse Arcana Ultimate
Spider-Man opted to do something we
don't see often and create an evil Peter
Parker now the rules within this Show's
first few seasons is that everyone's a
terrible person except Peter and Peter's
a nice guy but he's insufferable
annoying and unfunny but those god-awful
adaptations of their comic counterparts
were later replaced with more spider
themed team team members including a
universe displaced Brooklyn Spider-Man
after having him be a regular on the
show for a while a Multiverse incursion
begins due to the artifact that brought
him to this universe The Siege perilous
being shattered so it's actually it's
pretty much just using the setup from
Shattered Dimensions and some of the
visuals as well
kind of neat that the cartoon is taking
cues from the game for once instead of
the other way around so the two
Spider-Man are off on a multiversal
scavenger hunt to find all the pieces of
the McGuffin before anyone else can the
first weird Universe they drop into is a
Victorian London version of New York
that's infested with vampires instead of
being a loser super villain who can't
compress his web shooters small enough
to fit in a watch and then gets killed
by Venom blood spider is this world's
Peter Parker turned vampire Hunter I
always thought Ben diskin should get
another chance at voicing Spider-Man
after Ultimate Alliance 2 so this is
cool to see
and he was spider ham in these two
I also think having the king of the
vampires in this universe be the lizard
of all characters is a really fun comic
Booky Choice it's not obvious like
having it just be Dracula or some blade
adjacent character
plus the character conflicts are more
interesting here than the first
spider-verse Arc because blood spider
wants to steal the magic McGuffin to
finally kill all vampires and Mr no
killing except when it's Wolverine and
you're mad is like nah and has to come
up with a non-lethal way to cure the
vampires
then we get a teaser at the villain wolf
spider it's overall a nice start to this
Arc and doing one Universe for the whole
episode lets the plot have way more room
to breathe however the next episode goes
back to that two-in-one format and
they're both a lot more simple
these aren't any universes based
directly on any Comics it's just right
Spiderman and a cowboy Spider-Man which
isn't all that creative All Things
Considered but I do like this weird
dysfunctional crew of webbeard Howard
the Duck and the Guardians of the Galaxy
themed pirate ship and the cowboy world
has Uncle Ben survive and be some kind
of superheroic badass and Carter Slade's
outfit and his nephew learns the great
responsibility lesson so that's like a
best case scenario usually universe is
where Uncle Ben lives lead to Peter
growing up to be an irresponsible jerk
so this one's a happy accident part 3 is
a lot stronger in my book when they go
back to the Noir dimension for one full
episode I think pulling in the Hulk for
this world is a really clever idea
because Joe fix it fits right in with
these characters and it's a great excuse
for him to be gray instead of green plus
he got Hammerhead and Mr negatives the
villain so it's a good time I really
like this one though I'm not sure about
making the black and white Universe in
color at the end
sort of messes up their aesthetic now
what are you gonna go up to the cartoon
Universe again and turn everyone into
normal animals leave them alone the
grayscale is the natural order of things
here you colorist bastards
I mean colorist isn't like the comic art
thing not as like a racial thing wolf
spider only gets a tiny part in this one
to keep him in mind but he doesn't
really appear at all in part two I think
they could have tried harder to make
that one tie in plot wise or at least
thematically with the other three
episodes since it really just feels like
a filler Adventure part 4 is where Peter
and Miles go to the Brooklyn Spider-Man
home Dimension and we get even more
small elements that'd go on to inspire
the spider-verse movie including both
Spider-Man being saved by spider Gwen in
this show she's a non-super powered
human that gets spider powers from her
costume which is
uh uh I don't know take it or leave it
but look it's the spider cave and it's
managed by the Aunt May of the Dead
Peter Parker in Miles home Dimension I
also think this show partially inspired
insomniac's take on Miles by having his
father die at some point in his mom
supporting his superhero career as a
single parent after all the teasing we
finally get to meet wolf spider and
learn what his plan is he's going to
turn himself into the toughest spider in
the Multiverse by draining the life
force of all the others kinda like that
the amazing spider guy from The Hulk
Deadpool and Spidey crossover in the
comics except that guy was trying to use
the extra spider powers he stole to be a
hero
Gwen stole that guy's name because she's
really hard to Market to the mainstream
I guess that's what you get when your
character is basically like three inside
jokes wrapped in one
oh wait no that's gwenpool my world had
a Miles Morales too and your life will
end as his did in pain and misery by my
hand wolf spider is just an irredeemable
evil scumbag and it's pretty refreshing
also I love that wolf spider is voiced
by Christopher Daniel Barnes to give
this some ties back to spider wars who's
that voice
shows evil Spider-Man wanted some
Redemption the only other completely
evil Peter Parker I can think of is that
cannibalistic super strong one from the
universe where Punisher accidentally
turned everyone into flesh-eating
Savages but I think wolf spider has a
cooler design and more staying power if
they ever want to use him again plus
he's better at getting his Mani Petty
appointments than the zombie Lord guy I
can't say the climax makes a ton of
sense wolf spider absorbs all of the
spiders and then Peter just allows
himself to get got to but thankfully is
brought into this metaphorical astral
plane thing to Rally the other spider
people to just like
Escape it's one of those willpower
things but I guess Pete's just lucky
that it worked instead of your life
force being absorbed and it all just
goes dark
or puts you in some kind of solo
hellscape with no access to the other
guys on the off chance that there's some
kind of afterlife when your soul is
ripped out of your body via magic I'll
just rally everyone else's ghosts like
in Finding Nemo to swim down to defeat
the villain long gone are the days where
Spider-Man outsmarts the bad guy in a
clever way that exploits their strength
against them now he just uses the power
of friendship or whatever
you train the power of Heroes what
what's happening to me someone as evil
as you you poisoned yourself by taking
our life forces you drank too much good
guy juice and it made you a bad guy
tummy hurt wait that sounds weird the
day is saved and Miles makes a conscious
decision to move into the other Universe
with his mom instead of getting put
there by an omniscient God thing and
then having really ambiguous memory of
that for the next 10 years ultimate
Spider-Man's two spider-verse events are
some of the very first adaptations of
the comic Arc and they came out almost
right after the book itself being as
close and release as they are the two of
them seem to be companion pieces when
looked at for future adaptations because
he's so Central to the interpersonal
conflicts in the original story arc
where he and Peter are arguing for the
position of the spider-verse leader I'd
have liked to see superior Spider-Man in
either of these arcs but his cartoon
debut wouldn't be until
um well anyway seeing as how these two
arcs inspired a fair amount of story
choices in the Cinematic spider verse
I'd hope that wolf spider could catch on
in another medium too since we don't
have like a recurring villain version of
Peter Parker though for the moment it
seems like the movies and Comics will
stick to pre-established villains from
Spidey history for the multiversal
events if he does appear again though he
needs a better haircut
I always get mad at YouTube for not
putting my videos in the subscription
box because people will comment finally
Xavier uploads again after all these
years not knowing three other videos
came out within the last month already
so maybe that stupid Bell icon thing
will help you remember I exist if you
want other ways to support the channel
you can always go hit up that patreon
for early videos and exclusive stuff
because it's just a dollar I'm not
kidding it's only one dollar Isn't that
cool if everyone who watched this video
donated one dollar a month I'd be able
to afford a house for myself so that
would be that would be really cool you
can also check out our merch on T public
or just buy some of my random stuff on
eBay I have a pretty substantial
collection of old toys that are still in
the box in perfect condition so go take
a look in case you find something you
like and lastly since this is a YouTube
video and you probably play fortnite
drop my Creator quote Xavier GM next
time you buy a silly dancer cool
character skin really helps me out
see you next time
[Music]
foreign